the national jhand armory intervention
group commonly abbreviated to gog in is
an elite tactical police unit of the
French national shown gallery its
missions include counterterrorism
hostage rescue national threat
surveillance protection of government
personnel and targeting organized crime
GOG n was established in 1974 following
the Munich massacre in Germany which
happened during the 1972 Olympic Games
initially created as a relatively small
tactical unit specializing in sensitive
hostage situations it has since grown
into a larger and more diverse
organization of nearly 400 members with
expanded responsibilities gog and shares
the jurisdiction of the french territory
with the National Police Special
Response units Jia Jian is headquartered
in Versailles near Paris although most
of its operations take place in France
the unit as a component of the French
Armed Forces can operate anywhere in the
world many of its missions are secret
and members are not allowed to be
publicly photographed since its
formation Jia Jian has been involved for
over 1,800 missions and rescued more
than 600 hostages making it one of the
most experienced counterterrorism units
in the world after the reactivation of
team rainbow in 2015 five Jia Jian
agents were recruited to bring their
skills and expertise to assist in the
fight against terrorism on a global
scale these agents were called doc ROC
twitch Montaigne and Lyon
[Music]
[Music]
I've learned from experience that the
place to save lives is in the field not
an office
[Music]
and sometimes the only way to save a
life is to take one Gustav katieb code
named doc is a defending operator in
team rainbow doc is of French and
Algerian descent and has grown up in
Paris in a wealthy family he comes from
both a medicine and military background
and has well-respected lineage in a
second year of studying medicine with
the prestigious Paris decart University
he answered the appeal for volunteers
and Doctors Without Borders he
subsequently volunteered numerous times
on emergency frontline missions around
the world at the age of 20
dr. Klein a prominent private medical
practice in favour of a career with the
French defense health service dots main
discipline is toxicology and
ecotoxicology he is authored and
contributed reports to the European
Centre for disease prevention and
control studies on biological agents and
their effects on at-risk populations and
damaged environments doc continues to
volunteer with Doctors Without Borders
recognizing the ongoing need for doctors
he is a highly regarded medical officer
in the French army special forces
command doc shows a high degree of
empathy for human suffering he sees the
military service especially the role of
counterterrorism units like geo GM as
noble in their commitment to the
protection of civilians he considers the
frontline to be as natural habitat as it
gives them the opportunity to have
direct influence and impact on the
well-being of the unit as inclination to
conflict resolution makes him a valuable
asset
DOX wealthy upbringing could have easily
turned up into a narcissist yet he's one
of the most accessible and thoughtful
people you'll ever meet
initially he wasn't very interested in
being a doctor the direction seems to
have come from a family tradition
although it's clear that his
grandfather's military service was also
a strong motivation doc admits that he
had almost quit at the end of his first
year because he had no passion for his
work but during the second year got
volunteered for Doctors Without Borders
for the first time and the experience of
their first trip still resonates with
them the poverty the chronic lack of
supplies in the desperate needs of the
people he remembers the look of worry on
the mother's faces as they gathered near
tents and this is where he found his
passion at last encountering people have
so little doc felt ashamed and
embarrassed of the life he lived field
reports reflect Doc's selfless actions
and even though he's a doctor he's
explicitly chosen roles and combat
situations during a frontline operation
in East Africa local militias stormed
the hospital with Doc work and all the
patients had fought so hard to save were
killed from these horrendous events doc
realized that it was within his power to
save even more lives it feels to take on
more of a combat role to dr. passion for
conflict resolution is just one of a
dozen skills that make it an asset to
Rambo it's clear that his team trusts
and respects them while thorough medical
care is obviously preferred in the case
of major combat injuries fast paced
real-world operations require a more
flexible approach to the treatment of
field and URIs the reviving jolt that
doc administers can often spell the
difference between the mission success
and failure where every second is
precious
a handheld trigger operated pistol
powered by a pressurized co2 church
delivering a one milligram dose of 15
different in a saline solution the stone
pistol delivers the necessary dose of
epinephrine to stimulate the heart and
flood the cardiovascular system with
adrenaline the shot also includes micro
pellets that X's in an instant blood
clotting agent that moved quickly
through the circulatory system sealing
any internal bleeding and damaged blood
vessels they also fill in open wounds
from the inside and prevent soldiers
from bleeding out I trust that the
ceramic trauma plate I'm wearing will
stop a 357 magnum round traveling at 490
meters per second I trust myself not to
move not to flinch
I trust my teammates
and they trust me Julian Nizar
codenamed rook was defending operator
and team rainbow rook was a youngest son
of a working-class family his father was
a respected stonemason while his mother
helped numerous jobs both of them
informed his sense of architectural
design and precision helping him earn
top rankings in school along with
Brookes intellectual interests he
excelled in athletics from an early age
including track and field fencing and
cycling he later dropped out of
university to circle across France at
age 18 the Jean de Marie have listed his
father for an anti-corruption stint with
local businesses Brooke was fascinated
by the level of planning required by the
police he eventually enlisted in the
gendarmerie Nationale and was assigned
to the Highway Patrol unit Luke thrived
in his training which includes
specialized qualifications and weapons
surveillance and Criminal Investigations
his adaptability put him at the top of
the list and military and defensive
courses quickly capturing GOG ins
attention his first operations and their
group merged all the ingredients to
fulfill his relentless desire for
challenges and adventure specializing in
hostage rescue and surveillance Brookes
list of successful interventions is
comprehensive
Rooker's idealistic and trusting he can
be impulsive and must self-regulate in
order to remain on task when his focus
is clear he is decisive and driven to
complete the task at hand what stands
out is his ability to adapt to demands
Brookes interests are wide reaching and
his parents have played a large part in
this attribute of his personality Brooke
and his sister were encouraged to be
curious about everything Brookes father
was a stonemason which requires
imagination precision and dedication his
mother's ability to explore different
vocations with enthusiasm or keeping
street busker florists tour guide and
ship all strongly influenced how Rick
adapts to challenges and what goals he
sets out for himself
field reports reflect some of rock's
chameleon-like way of emerging into
whatever role is required dropping out
of university to circle around France
give him his first sense of freedom and
then his world expanded even further
when he returned right from the
beginning
Rick remembers appreciating the broad
spectrum of skills and range of
expertise required to be in law
enforcement in military
every day is different Rooker's one of
the more consistent optimists on the
team
his ability to energize other
specialists is important and he is
certainly well liked
the GI jeans are one Rhino Armour
contains a hot pressed Boren ceramic
plate designed to stop small arms fire
from penetrating chest cavity as well as
offering small protection against trauma
caused by back face deformation they are
stored in a lightweight sturdy sexual
for rapid field deployment the trauma
plates were initially designed as a
low-profile ballistic shield for trust
exercises Brooke was first introduced to
the trauma plate when he was on the
receiving end of a 357 magnum the
protection they provide and the ease at
which the damage plate could be replaced
made the trauma plates a valuable
addition to the team rainbows defenses
the Arwen's composition of boron ceramic
plates can limit the damage from small
arms and effectively bias time for the
team from fatal impacts so that medical
assistants can reach the team in time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Geel today codenamed Montaigne is an
attacking operator in team rainbow the
son of an army officer and school
teacher here's the middle of four
siblings with two older brothers and a
younger sister a few years after
graduating high school
Montaigne began his law enforcement
career as a uniformed police officer in
the National John Todd Murray
they used his imposing prisons whenever
there was a need to show strong police
presence earning him a spot in the
mobile jean armory where the focus was
on crowd control as well as military and
counterterrorism patrol missions
Montana's push for extensive training
provided him with a broad skillset and
earned him with a position in the GI GN
after many years of service and
involvement in numerous incidents such
as the 1994 French airline hijacking
Montaigne has become the longest-serving
Gog and operative Montaigne is a
certified GOG an instructor when not
deployed with rainbow his Biss utilized
for his breaching techniques but also
his training in combat engineering and
reconnaissance Montaigne is considered
highly dependable by his peers his
steady nerves have allowed him to take
control of complex high-stress
situations during the tenure of this
career as a trainer
Montaigne is stern with new recruits but
always tries to remain fair he prefers
to lead by example he's a man of few
words even among his friends
Montaigne is happy with how Rainbow
continues to evolve and is proud to be a
part of it although an instructor he's
always willing to learn from his peers
and is trying to stretch beyond his
comfort zone
Montaigne has a naturally protective
nature his choice to enter law
enforcement speaks more to that than his
family's military history
Montana's family raised them to be
protectors and his two brothers are also
in the military the appearance would
often tell him of stories of various
ancestors who fought for what was right
he believes that education is the
solution to many of the world's problems
the sister finished a police training
have switched to teaching when she felt
there was where she could do the most
good
Montaigne has some doubts about his role
in rainbow many of the operators are
exceptionally skilled with languages
Montaigne isn't this isn't an issue for
the team
but even a perceived weakness can be
debilitating lyric was first issued in
the late 1980s a composite of reinforced
alloys and Kevlar its sturdiness and
well-designed collapsible feature has
made it a staple and gog and operations
for nearly 30 years
Montana's shield is the only original
nirach still in service without seen its
fair share of conflict the devices
become an extension of Montaigne having
saved his life and members of the team
on multiple occasions it'll most likely
remain on active duty until he retires
you have a few spare hours I'd love to
show the details of how this device is a
masterpiece of design critical
independent gearboxes enabling zero to
20 in under four seconds ten kilometers
of internal wiring 1,100 expertly
machine and assemble components flawless
control out of the 300 meters but all my
team needs to know is does it do the job
or doesn't it and let me tell you right
now it does the job immanuel p shop
codenamed twitch is an attacking
operator at team rainbow twitch grew up
in a family of academics in the historic
city of nazi France where the children
were encouraged to excel in maths
science and technology early
participation and sponsored computer
programming competitions lead to a
joining the army cadets at 16 almost
immediately
who talent was recognized particularly
in robotics her superiors quickly
encouraged twitch to study engineering
while continuing a career in the
military from the start
Twitter's focus has been on the adaptive
the technology that eight soldiers in
the field while there is much praise for
a technological achievements which is
tactical prowess and ability to
problem-solve quickly make her a crucial
operational asset Twitch's unique
combination of talents make a well
suited for Gog and later Rambo in 2015
field reports describe twitch as
technologically creative but this
doesn't encapsulate all of who she is
this more deep and surprises to twitch
than anyone expects there's some
academic rivalry between twitch and a
sister a physicist of nothing series is
an endemic of the per fiction hood
family instilled in their children
her father told her to strive to be
incredible every day and that will
resonate out into the universe the
rainbow team speaks highly of her both
operationally and in a social setting
she's a very hands-on researcher the
manner in which she gets right up close
to a robot interacting with a device on
would a child or pet illustrates her
innate compassion twitch is currently
teaching AI empathy so that it can in
turn teach fields her background and
interest in AI means that one of
Twitch's favorite pastimes is people
watching whether it's settling into a
restaurant or taking a bus she goes
wherever there are crowds and studies
behavior travel to exciter the list of
where she hasn't been is shorter than
where she has in 2019 team rainbow loses
contact with kuvira and she's gone off
the grid Valkyrie and twitch go on a
search and find that she's in Bolivia
with the help of the ghosts twitch works
alongside while Valkyrie guides him from
HQ
after twitching the ghosts investigate a
crash truck they find out that kuvira is
searching for a man in the cartel as
twitchin the ghosts looked through the
man's apartment to find out that the
cartel member is an undercover Brazilian
police officer the Caviar's brother the
team links up with kuvira at the Liberto
chemical institute and together they
find a rescue her brother and extract
him
the shop drone can scout locations and
driven electronics shop via probes that
incapacitates electrical devices and can
be used as a distraction towards
hostiles the first official deployment
of the irst model one was during a
hostage situation in Paris a mentally
unstable suspect barricaded himself in a
convenience store along with several
hostages gog and was deployed and sought
to resolve the situation without
violence which was on site and was able
to maneuver the drone close enough to
the suspect to deliver a slight shock
forcing the suspect to drop his weapon
where he was incapacitated by an
undercover operative the incident was
resolved with zero fatalities ricin
anthrax sarin gas Ebola VX gas
Chimaera viruses
some enemies are invisible but the CBR
and threat unit is rainbows shield
against those enemies that can kill you
with a single drop of blood nanobots
online the brother I mean forever much
[Music]
or one wrong breath Olivia flama
codenamed lion is an attacking operator
and team rainbow lion was born to a
conservative wealthy family his parents
and older sister were in medicine and
are developed Catholics he was smart and
arrogant but he believed rebellion was a
better use of his intellect it was fun
to act out against expectation to drink
and to party at least it was until he
got his girlfriend clear pregnant he
tried to convince Claire to get an
abortion but she refused once his
parents found out about the pregnancy
they kicked him out of the house it was
the last straw and a string of bad
behavior depressed line went on a drug
and alcohol fueled bender getting
trashed enough to land in the hospital
that was his wake-up call he was 18 and
nearly homeless so he joined the French
army out of desperation he needed
purpose military life was hard but
rewarding lion took solace and purpose
and struggled to break the old habits he
started sending money to clear to
support their newborn son even though
she did not want to see him he became a
second-level in combat rescuer and
joined the 2nd Dragoon regiment in their
role as a CBRN reaction force he also
developed a close relationship the
regiment's Catholic chaplain the air
travel who eventually spoke to Claire
and convinced her that Lyon regretted
dissections he arranged a reunion for
them it was a hard moment for Lyon he
met a son Alexis the child he wanted
aborted and the reality of this decision
hit him hard he had been selfish pushing
his girlfriend to do something because
it inconvenience him more so clear was
about to get married and alexis was
already calling someone else
steady everything he had done putting
his loved one through hell
shoved him into a wild depression it
almost cost him his rank chaplain dear
Trent help lying through this crisis and
with it he returned to the Catholic
Church Lyon swore that he'd do
everything possible to rectify the pain
that he caused so he worked harder and
sought more challenges
he qualified to join the Jia Jian as the
new biohazard expert using drones to
maintain and hold quarantine parameters
he focused on his duty or making things
right no matter how much it hurt him in
the process his feelings were irrelevant
what mattered was strict observation of
stuti during a yellow fever outbreak in
Sudan while protecting a field
investigation team his loud voice scared
a front and walked back and he gained
his nickname Lian from the locals in
2015 the army asked him to lead that
second dragoons into West Africa to
assist medical personnel fighting the
Ebola epidemic tragedy ensued and the
decisions Lian made for safety reasons
put him at odds with doc who blamed him
for the death of several medical
personnel on site including Doc's
colleague the tension between the two
continues to this day and team rainbow
Lian immediately proved his value to
team rainbow when he and finca uncovered
the source of mysterious mist that came
ashore in Sussex and poisoned people
though he claims he shares their success
with twitch who provided him with a new
aerial drone to locate the miss blue
line has managed to stay in the Suttons
life but it's an awkward relationship
Alexis does not know how to call him
father and Lian is not sure of what it
means to be a dad in the day to day his
mended bridges with his parents and
sister has returned to the catholic
faith healing those wounds and while his
decision to be a soldier bothers them he
is no longer the thoughtless rebel he is
not a soldier to make life easy on a
soul he bears the responsibility for
what he has done
even though be a trend constantly
reminds him there forgiveness is in the
heart of God liners are by the books
operator because he doesn't trust his
civilian instincts rules give him
structure and allow him to control what
he considers the piteå parts of his
personality they give him a safety net
with conscience or arrogance could
otherwise weaken his resolve and hurt
more lives he bears the weight of
responsibility for what he has done and
pushes himself to the limits as a form
of corporal punishment
unfortunately lion is arrogant and has
roped some people within Jia Jian and
Rambo the wrong way doc thinks he lacks
the empathy necessary to help in a
medical crisis while iron thanks Doc's
humanitarianism is a liability twitch is
not happy about being caught in the
middle of this fight lions closest
friend and Jia Jian is Montaigne
but when Thatcher punch know that Lane
after he said the wrong thing during a
training exercise lion almost brought
the Jia Jian and essayist blows Lian
spends most of the social time at church
volunteering where he can or at his
apartment reading and staying out of
trouble while listening to the angry
albums of his teenage years which
provided him with an aerial drone while
he served in Jia Jian the e 1d helpline
maintained quarantine by detecting
movement in an area giving an overview
of hot zones or of the battlefield his
drunken state airborne indefinitely but
he must choose the right moment to
perform askance
[Music]
I must apologize for my lack of
consistency and uploads over the last
little while YouTube has been messing
with me a bit lately
first half my channel got demonetised
then it was upgrade to the whole channel
giving to monetized after submitting
manual reviews on almost every single
video it's almost gone completely back
to normal
however now even though I've set the
channel to set this channel not made for
kids I've had a number of videos
overturned and sit as made for kids I've
also had strikes added to my account and
then removed shortly after which was
actually more confusing than receiving
them in the first place and to top it
off every video I now upload is
instantly being demonetised
depending manual reviews so yeah not
hugely motivating I know this will pass
same thing happened last time YouTube
made some updates I have just got to
ride it out anyway I hope you've enjoyed
this video and I'll catch you on the
next one Cheers